[Music]
[Music]
love underperformers that's right like
check this one out I does this no one
wanted it it's called bald eagles trying
to hide their baldness not fooling
anyone look at this guy's got the old
bandana like your real badass that's not
gonna work and then look at this one at
the bottom right here that's not foolin
anybody yeah it's not working up pretty
look at this one right here this is
Annie fascinating coffee table book
raisins reminiscing about when they were
grapes thinking back to the good old
days better there there's a raisin right
there thing about the time he was great
but he was president he was president
grape he was president crepe look at
this raisin on this bagel thinking about
the time he was in a rock band with some
other grapes three then look at this oh
yeah that was some crazy night with
those two other grapes what a what a
menage a great yeah ha ha did you just
say now how Greg gets a menagerie right
you should see yourself out look at this
one again I'll be gold we all love
national historic landmarks these are
rejected national historic landmarks
look at that right there
Lester Holt's birthplace Beach ma oh
come on that should have been in look at
that one right there Madonna's first
chiropractor I want wanted that one and
then we go down on the bottom yep I
gotta leave you there we go apartment
we're Baja then wrote
the dogs out
[Applause]
that's it he write that should be a
national historic landmark right there
all right I think you'll like this one
Steven Seagal with his ponytail stuck in
fatal elevator yeah look at this one
right here at a deli yeah that's I don't
want to get that order
he really does stay calm I gotta give
that to him happens all the time
- mom look at this one this is a whole
book of a whole ghost
these are ghosts that are just being
look at that he's trying to make some
pottery and that guy totally oh my god
you're not gonna believe this we're on
the back what I'm sorry put that up
again
I want to leave that in for the whole
hour one show where everybody is tuning
in take a look at that yeah I think the
worst thing is he left just go Sox on
you're gonna be go seed and he's got his
own signing on please take off your
ghost saw that guy is gonna wake up and
just not just be there right I'll be
fine yeah here we go this one's a little
strange but I like it closed sandwich
faraway horse that's what that is that's
what that is and it's got lots of
examples on the back then you can
looking in Hey
oh that's more of a wrap
right yes they're being pretty close
with Stefan you know what and--which I
would if this was a real book oh they're
not real
I would I would buy this and watch that
yeah I would what not look through it
every morning right and then finally
there's this book that nobody wanted
okay who the invited Stephen King
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here's the hole yeah man that's the book
to get man yeah good one
you